la crise syrienne trouve son origine
dans le printemps arabe de 2011
mais pendant que les régimes
autoritaires en tunisie et en egypte par
exemple vont s'effondrer
bachar al assad vivent à résister malgré
une farouche rébellion il faut dire que
chaque camp à ses appuis dans la région
en fonction des confessions religieuses
de côté les pays arabes sunnites comme
la turquie la jordanie ou encore
l'arabie saoudite soutiennent les
rebelles de l'autre les chiites comme
l'iran l'irak ou le hezbollah libanais
sont derrière al assad
un nouveau joueur va apparaître sur
l'échiquier syrien en 2013 c'est le
groupe armé état islamique
ce groupe djihadiste fondée en irak
étant rapidement son influence sur la
syrie mais aussi sur le reste du monde
sur le terreau et le ive a affronté des
combattants kurdes qui rêvent de leur
propre état dans la région les grandes
puissances ont aussi un rôle à jouer
dans la crise syrienne
la russie soutient le régime alors que
les etats-unis et les pays européens
sont deux côtés de la rébellion
près de cinq ans après le début de la
crise la situation semble s'enliser pour
de bon
le conflit a déjà fait plus de deux cent
cinquante mille morts les syriens à bout
de ressources tant par tous les moyens
de fuir le pays